we're taking the news about the new
highly mutated covet 19 variant very
seriously
we do know that mutations could lead to
the emergence and spread of even more
concerning variants of the virus
that could spread worldwide within a few
months
it is now important that all of us in
europe act very swiftly
decisively and united
the european commission has today
proposed to member states
to activate the emergency brake on
travel from countries in southern africa
and other countries affected
to limit the spread of the new variant
all air travel to these countries should
be suspended
they should be suspended until we have a
clear understanding
about the danger posed by this new
variant
and travelers returning from this region
should respect strict quarantine rules
i've spoken about the situation today
with scientists and vaccine
manufacturers
they too
fully support such
precautionary measures to avoid
international spreading of the
concerning variant
it also depends on all of us as citizens
to contribute to a better control of the
pandemic
please get vaccinated as soon as
possible if not done yet